[Music]
are you excited for the switch well if
you just can't wait then boy do I have
some news for you neogaf user hip hop
the robot uploaded a video of them using
the switch setting it up and perusing
its menus I'm Matt this is a game spot
news update and make sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more coverage of
Nintendo's upcoming console the neogaf
user claims that the console was sent to
them early by an unnamed store and to
prove it they uploaded a video it starts
with them going through the system set
up and while the sequence of events is
pretty basic it gets more interesting as
they start going through the menus the
switch is a storage capacity of 32
gigabytes but we can see in the video
that about six of those are taken up by
the OS leaving players with around 26
gigabytes for game storage of course you
can always buy a microSD card to expand
that space but you already spent three
hundred dollars on a console without an
additional memory card The Legend of
Zelda breath of the wild is going to
take up more than half of the switches
storage that's kind of a bummer the
Nintendo switch releases officially on
March third and some of its launch
titles include breath of the wild one to
switch and the binding of isaac
afterbirth plus there's still about two
weeks left to go until we can play it
for ourselves so in the meantime why not
check out the latest episode of the
lobby where we discuss whether the
switch will hurt or help the 3ds
you